another victim of climate change a
prized horse succumbs to the searing
heat
here an exhausted lamb was left behind
by a migrating herd for wild animals to
devour his losses pile up
mohammed rounds of his cattle and family
and head towards the border with
cameroon
we are leaving to where the pastures
greener and the weather's more bearable
the migration will save what's left of
my cattle the drought and the rising
heat have taken so much away from me
far removed from what world leaders are
doing at the climate change summit he's
just trying to catch his losses and
recover even if that means risking
attacks by bandits boko haram and
corrupt officials as he crosses the
child cameroon border
muhammad jibrin expects the dry period
and his losses to continue
the rains have failed us and the
unbearable heat is drying up the little
water that we have it's painful to watch
your animals die and there's nothing you
can do about it
he's not sure if he will have any cattle
left before the rain's return
while politicians and experts discuss
how to slow global warming activists say
people in the sahel are already living
the gloomy future the leaders are
talking about
they say the region continues to see
rising temperatures
and fear it could get worse
effective amounts come to the disease i
can definitely tell you that in this
region time has in fact run out
it's up to us to act and mitigate the
impact
armed groups still occupy light swathes
of territory further limiting access to
water and land for agriculture
as the impact of climate change becomes
clear pastoralists are forced to make a
difficult decision to sell off their
animals at very low prices or let them
die and when they bring them to markets
like this they find few people can
afford to buy them
ahmed idris al jazeera jamina